it was a popular mid-flight announcement
if you choose to you may remove your
mask
seeing everybody's
ready when they announced it on the
plane everyone just cheered and ripped
their mask off
the Court ruling that covid-19
researchers say will make the divided
States of America even more vulnerable
then this federal judge out of Florida
decides that she's a public health
expert and is of subverting all of it I
think it's a I think it's a mistake and
I think a lot of people will get coveted
unnecessarily Canadian experts agree if
no one's wearing masks anymore and we're
still in the throes of the sixth wave
that transmission will increase simple
as that in a statement to Global News
Transport Canada says there is no change
to the current policy in Canada a policy
that requires masks on all Canadian
Airlines at all flights leaving or
coming to this country some Canadians
like the American ruling I'm glad Ben
glad I mean I don't like the mask bogs
up my eyes and stuff so but many other
Travelers say masks are still necessary
that they'd keep wearing them even if
they were no longer mandated as long as
this pandemic is still in full swing
which I believe it still is I'm going to
wear a mask until the numbers have
disappeared I'm an immunocompromised and
it wouldn't be good so my husband is 81.
um so this is this we didn't plan on
this I would still wear a mask
um yeah and if it was the
epidemiologists that are that are
suggesting it as well I would still wear
masks this epidemiologist says those
comments do not surprise him as a nation
Canadians for the most part are more
community-minded or more about
self-sacrifice for the public good not
that Americans aren't but we are to a
greater degree especially around Public
Health
the U.S decision covers all mass transit
unless local jurisdictions impose their
own orders some Airlines say staff at
the check-in counters will keep wearing
masks for now as lawmakers and medical
authorities wrestle with their next
Maneuvers in a deeply divisive pandemic
Ross Lord Global News